do what you love and the money will
follow only after that before okay it's
a lot of crap
clarity is power and what is power the
power is the ability to take action
don't wait nobody's gonna come rescue
you know what it's gonna save you wanna
soar get a mentor
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best day and lock and
some of his best life-changing advice
mentor me Dan
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have energy you don't have enough
energy how do you expect to accomplish
anything significant accomplish your
goals when you don't have enough energy
you notice the society puts down and
look down on people they have high
energy imagine you're going to school
you're going to work you're going back
to your office you're going back to your
business and suddenly you're so
energetic and you have you're all hyped
up what would people say to you what's
wrong with you dude
like calm them down relax why are you so
excited
but somehow you have low energy hey man
that's okay you know what Feinstein
stands for freaked out in debt not
making enough money emotionally stressed
out f ing that's what it stands for I
mind a is fine
that's what finance but somehow you've
high energy it is wrong you won't have
energy you got to move laughing my
martial art background you watch my
video you follow my work you know move
jumping jack pushup walk yoga whatever
the [ __ ] it takes move your body when
you move you have more energy when you
sit there all day for hours how the hell
can you have energy movement creates
energy so if you're sitting there for a
long day get up stand up walk around do
something I know jumpin up and down
water it is do something rule number two
love what you do how many of you heard
of the saying that you know do what you
love and the money will follow
how many decide don't do that before
okay it's a load of crap
okay let me ask you this let me ask you
this how many of you are doing what you
love and you are following your passion
and you're wondering what the hell is
the money so that dog doesn't hurt it
does not work you see it's the other day
I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine he's an international
sales trainer and he travels around the
world and goes into companies and and
trains different companies and we were
having this discussion about you know do
what you love and the money will follow
and then he said to me you know Dan you
know what I would love to do I would
love to just stay home spend time with
my kids holding my wife one hand you
know holding a beer and watching a
hockey game but the problem is you know
what then I can't figure out to get
people to watch me do that and pay me so
until then I had to get on the road and
travel and train it's a lot of people
yes you want to follow your passion but
you better make sure your passion makes
you money you better make sure can you
build a Bible business from it can you
get rich at it
yes follow your passion I love what I do
I love what I do I'm a very passionate
guy but there are certain things in my
business that that I didn't like to do
while I was building a company nowadays
yes I spend 90% of my time doing what I
love
let me give an example I love speaking I
love speaking teaching business I could
be here all day no scrip don't need a
scrip
problem is I hate traveling
hate it and I got here last night this
is like it was horrible but it's because
it's because I am willing to do what I
don't like to do that's what allows me
to do what I do like to do does that
make sense so lesson number two write
this down it's not to you what you love
and money will follow is love what you
do and you'd be damn good at what you do
and you'd be exceptional at what you do
rule number three get clarity when it
comes to reading I read a book sometimes
if I'm looking for any book that I read
I have a simple question I want to get
through what are the three ideas that I
can get from the book that can implement
right now just sweetie not 10 not 20 not
100 three ideas if I could get those
three ideas from the first three
chapters I'll highlight those I will
take those and I'll put the book away
one of the most powerful tool on the
ball most powerful mindset you need to
have in life on business is clarity and
clarity is power clarity is power and
what is power the power is the ability
to take action
so if the more you read the more
confused that you get it gives you less
clarity it means it takes away from your
power if more reading gives you more
clarity and gives you more ability to
act that's good that's powerful right
that's best on the right track so
there's a big difference between
information and knowledge and knowledge
to wisdom let me explain this would
gives you a lot of clarity information
is just facts data numbers figures
theories principles that's just
information there's a lot of information
on the Internet there's a lot of
information on YouTube there's a lot of
information on Google there's a lot of
information but information itself does
not help you it does not make you richer
it does not does not make you happier it
does not make you healthier it does not
make you smarter information is just
information it's like you go to school
right you're reading you're going to
class you you're your textbook there's a
lot of information in the textbook right
that's the first stage once you gather
enough information now you're
accumulating what I call knowledge so
you get a lot of information and you now
learn about the distinctions now you
take that information you apply or may
take that information and you take a
test that's knowledge after the test you
know after the exam in school oh that
works so oh no that was the wrong answer
or I didn't pass the the the exam or
here they're the mistakes that I got
wrong well you're learning from it right
that's accumulating your knowledge so a
lot of people they read books to acquire
information you watch me they're quite
information and you wonder how come I'm
watching a lot of videos I'm learning
but my life is do the same because you
haven't convert information to knowledge
and from knowledge into experience now
how to convert knowledge into experience
so now you get you acquire some
knowledge you've got to implement and
only way you get experience at u-dub a
lot right you make the mistakes you see
this stuff works right now you're
getting experience you're seeing a
pattern of things go goes back to the
the school example now you take enough
exams remember the class you take from
like grade 9 10 11 12 right now you're
taking of exams studying the same
subject for many years in a row now you
see a pattern okay I'm accumulating more
things I'm getting more experience of
what works and what doesn't now
experience that's much more valuable
it's more valuable than knowledge and
knowledge is more available information
so books itself is just information
information does not change your life
information doesn't change your life you
got to convert it by gathering a filter
into knowledge from knowledge now you
implement now you get to the next step
which is experience then from experience
from now you you have done it long
enough a long period of time now is
evolved into your wisdom a lot of people
are smart but they're not wise wisdom is
something completely different
okay wisdom
is knowing what not to do
wisdom is knowing when you don't have to
do something so let's say enough
experience you know what this is how I'm
going to make this work these are 20
things that I could do my experience
tells me these are the 20 things I could
do to make me successful wisdom is
knowing okay 19 leads is motion just do
this one that is the difference rule
number four get good habits we are what
we repeatedly do human beings we are
creatures of habits you notice that you
kind of do the same thing the same
routine over over and again and again
and again see become getting rich is not
an act it is a habit so it is staying
poor it's also not an act it's nothing
just happens to you it is a habit so let
me teach you the three best habits of
rich people the very first habit of rich
people and that is they count their
money pool people don't count their
money they get a paycheck they deposit a
paycheck they spend the money they have
no idea what the expenses are you have
no idea how the money flows you know
this poor people they enjoy a B they
have a job and wait till maybe once a
year when they found out they would text
return is the the Texas that I own is
how much of the pay they look at the
numbers they even look at the numbers
it's just okay all right
that's what how much I need to pay
without tax return and that's it look at
it maybe maybe once a year rich people
we don't do that we look at our numbers
regularly we are financially literate
I'm not a numbers person don't get me
wrong okay I'm a concept guy okay I'm a
big-picture thinker I'm a visionary but
I am very very careful and I'm very
aware how my money is flowing habit
number two is they pay themselves first
now you've heard of this before oh yeah
I know
then I've heard of this this before you
got to pay yourself do you know actually
what that means paying yourself doesn't
buy yourself a car it does
means taking that vacation it doesn't
mean that you know you would you know
you go blow money on entertainment oh
yeah I'm paying money myself
no that's paying everybody else when
you're buying a car you're paying the
automotive motive company when you're
buying a house you are paying the bank
when you are traveling you're paying the
the traveling agency you're paying the
hotel you're paying the the flight
company airplane company paying yourself
meaning that you put your money aside
and you invest your money now I'm not
talking about being frugal you know if
you know anything about me you know my
work I'm not talking about being food
girl and being cheap I'm talking about
taking a piss percentage of your income
and putting that aside pay yourself
first and save it and then you invest it
habit of rich people number three and
that is rich people are constantly
improving their earning ability because
you might be thinking Darren okay I want
to pay myself first but I'm not making
enough money I'm only making a few
dollars in a month i couldíve I couldn't
even afford to pay my bills how am I
gonna pay myself first first of all you
gotta have the habit of paying yourself
first if you're not paying yourself
first even a tiny small percentage when
you're making 30 40 50 60 $100,000 a
year I guarantee you when you're making
a million two million dollars a year
you're not paying yourself it is a habit
that I'm talking about and in order to
do that in order to be able to every
single year to be able to pay yourself
more and more and more and put into
investments you need to improve your
earning ability you need to find ways
how you can add value to the marketplace
how to add more value to the marketplace
so every single year your income is
going up every year if you've been
you've been working in house in the real
world and you have your own business and
your income kind of stays flat for the
last two or three five years and shame
on you it means you're not learning it
means you're not thinking it means
you're not growing every single year
your income you have to strive to
improve that your earning ability and
the rich people we're always constantly
looking for ways to improve our earning
ability but also looking for ways to end
leverage to apply leverage into what we
you rule number five show up you ask me
all the time where am i flying to your
city where am i going to fly to you Dan
would love to attend one of your
seminars when you come to my city the
answer is never what if I never come to
your city whatever never fly to your
town then what are you gonna do what if
I don't come three years five years ten
years you're gonna wait in ten years it
makes no sense
don't wait nobody's gonna come rescue
you know what it's gonna save you you
got to show up and you got to go to what
ever wherever it takes and remember
years ago when my mentor asked me and
say hey I won't have breakfast I flew to
LA just to have a single breakfast with
my mentor and you're waiting and you're
waiting and what are you waiting for
you're waiting for me come to the city
you're waiting for the perfect timing
you're waiting for everything is
perfectly lined up you're waiting for
what's convenient the problem is you put
your convenience ahead of your
conviction convenience and conviction
don't live on the same block and rule
number six the last home before a very
special bonus clip is sacrifice the
first five years of my business career
when I was getting started the first
five years I didn't take a single day
off I was working 12 to 14 hours a day
seven days a week for the first five
years while all my friends they were out
there drinking drinking and having
parties and chasing girls I was working
I sacrifice and me a lot of sacrifices I
believe if you don't sacrifice for your
dream then your dream becomes your
sacrifice so I made a decision I pay the
price
early on I spent a few years of my life
working on myself working on my business
doing the things that most people are
too lazy to do not willing
to do so I could have what most people
cannot have
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Dan on how to have a sense of
urgency that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions time to
move from just watching on the video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and even feeling bold
leave your replies in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to show up more to in your life
number two what are you willing to
sacrifice in order to show up and number
three what bad habits you need to swap
with a good one so you can show up more
consistently
the average human lifespan is 75 years
one-third of your life is spent sleeping
and outer third of your life is spent on
watching TV movies drinking and partying
traveling spending time with family and
friends playing video games commuting to
work buying groceries paying the bills
being stuck in traffic waiting in line
mowing the lawn cleaning up the house
and doing laundry 25 years left in the
first 18 years of your life you are
growing up you are learning to walk eat
run and talk you are totally dependent
on your parents and going to school
because you can't really think for
yourself call your own shots or know how
to be your own person that means you
have approximately seven years to make
your dreams come true and if you have a
job you probably spent most of that time
working for someone else instead of
building your own dream life is too
short to waste time on people
or inspired you life is too short to be
living somebody else's dream life is too
short to wait life is too short not to
take chances life is too short to wake
up with regrets
developed a sense of urgency in the
pursuit of success and freedom you must
step up to live life on your own terms
raise your standard Apple at the core
it's core value is that means that
people who passion can change now one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's suppose to mean
if you want more day and check out the
top ten rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
most people they listen to a webinar to
watch a video and they say oh this guy's
making whatever how much money online I
could do that and they jump into it